the Joe Rogan experience his britches
brother was a mixed martial arts
commentator who's a sports guy he did
world combat championships I think it
was called it was like he was like one
of the the he was the play-by-play guy
or the color yeah he was a play-by-play
guy and it was like the early days of
fighting when the UFC had just started
and hen's Oh Gracie fought Oleg Taktarov
and Richie's brother was the the
play-by-play commentator yeah like he
did the John Anik Mike Goldberg role
yeah I remember thinking this is so
crazy because I I don't think at the
time I had even done any work for the
UFC I think at the time I was just a fan
and I was just what usually started them
97 okay laughs 20 years 20 years nuts
I started in UFC 12 in Dothan Alabama
how was your first broadcast
um I they didn't give me any instruction
nobody told me what to do nobody told me
how to do it nobody told me [ __ ] they
just said do you want a gig interviewing
the fighters after the fights I was like
sure you know and then it was so
rinky-dink like we were in this weird
little [ __ ] hotel and this weird and
you know that's we were staying we flew
in there on a propeller plane the gig
was supposed to be in Buffalo New York
but New York state banned it at the last
minute so Bob meyerwitz who was the
owner of the company and Campbell
McLaren was the guy who hired me they
told me you're going down to Alabama
instead like what so I flew into one
part of Alabama and it took a Puddle
Jumper
and landed in Dothan and that was like
the place where they were allowed to do
the show there and there's this little
auditorium it wasn't very big at all and
the first show I ever worked at marked
the hammer Coleman beat of dan7 for the
UFC heavyweight title UFC 12 Vitor
Belfort made his debut and I was
actually training at Vitor school I was
a white belt Carlson Gracie's in 97 and
that's where via and I had been there
since 96 I started training there in 96
and then in 97 Vitor was making his UFC
debut and just by sheer luck I happened
to be at the actual gym with Carlos by
hetoh and Mario Sperry and all these
like just assassins back then and I got
to be the post-fight interview guy yeah
it was nuts man that's me yeah my
earring oh so cute a little cutie pie
yeah so that was way way back in the
dizzy man 1997 Rita Medeiros there's
Vitor when you think in 97 you like [ __ ]
I was doing comedy seven years by that
point like it's a long time ago when I
was already in the business yeah I was
nine years in at that point in comedy
because I started in 88 yeah and I
didn't book gigs along I actually had to
quit because it was costing me money
because like if I would go to do a UFC I
don't remember how much I made it wasn't
that much to do the interview stuff but
then if I could do a comedy gig I could
make like two grand for a weekend right
so I was like why am i doing that when I
can make two grand like what am i doing
I'm like him like one instead of two
sorry it was just costing me money
anything that kind of made a comedy was
difficult - it was but for me my life
started with martial arts I mean that
was also you know I started in 88 and
the last time I fought was 89 so that
was probably you know somewhere in the
neighborhood of you know eight years
since my like serious competition days
so I still loved it I was still into it
and I was loving that this new thing was
around so I was happy to be there even
though it wasn't like it wasn't
affecting my career in a good way in
fact the people that were I was on
radio at the time and the people that
were the producers were like what the
[ __ ] are you doing like why are you
doing this like why would why would they
they treated me like I was going off to
do like porn right what is this [ __ ]
violent thing enjoying about and being a
part of and putting your face on but
yeah and I was like an expert like I was
the expert interviewer asking people
questions doing things like you're
attaching yourself to cage fighting the
[ __ ] is wrong with you but I loved it
man I loved it I'm so excited to see
this happen because we had always
wondered when when I started doing
martial arts you know I started in
karate I did like a little bit of kung
fu then I did Karate Kung Fu was like
one lesson and then a little bit of
karate but then I got balls deep in a
taekwondo but we all we ever everybody
always wanted to know what was the best
martial art and I switched from
Taekwondo and I started doing kickboxing
and boxing because I realized like my
hands were terrible and then I'm like
man I mean I thought it was good because
I was good at Taekwondo but this boxing
stuff is more important to learn I need
to learn that and then I started doing
jiu-jitsu and getting strangled my [ __ ]
I don't know anything and I remember
thinking when the UFC came along finally
we're gonna figure out what works
[Applause]